arrowman's bringing some energy today
rock
coming in hot barrel man and rock
freddie peralta
second best tra in the national league
he is ready to roll
and he's got a 128 opponent batting
average the best in baseball i mean he
has been unbelievable
one on for pittsburgh rodolfo castro
is going to be the better that's the
swing of the miss throw to seconds in
time
strike him out throw him out double play
manny pina
just fired a laser to second base
quick feet straight as a string pretty
close but the out
was called at second one and two the
count two men are
on two outs in the first some stress
pitches early
and a ground ball knocked down arrears
to his feet thrown to first on a hop
escobar picks it safe is the call
they're going to challenge it i think
escobar
fumbled with it briefly he thought he
had secured it before nagowski hit the
bag does he control the baseball and is
the foot on the bag
oh yeah he's out yeah that'll be it out
alfonso marquez says
you're out getting over steven brought
makes his season debut today
he's been out with a long-term injury
that he suffered in spring training
and the pitch bouncing ball over the
head of the pitcher
shortstop newman scoops it behind second
throws on and gets wong and
you can see brawl thought about trying
to go up and grab it and then thought
better of it runners at the corners with
two away
brings up tyrone taylor here's the pitch
ground ball to third castro
long throw again and gets him on the
money and brawl
pitches through some traffic and after
one it's the bucks nothing brewers
nothing
peralta deals again struck him out
swinging whoo nasty bender down low and
away and he went after it
wilmer depot is the batter now three and
two and a defoe
swing at a miss defoe strikes out
freddie peralta with back-to-back case
got him on a fastball
yeah fastball down and in 94 miles an
hour
jumping into that strike zone 2-2
swinging to miss got him with the
breaking ball finally finished off brawl
peralta with his fourth strikeout
the one-two swinging a foul tip held on
to
by manny pina that ends the inning one
pitch to wong
swing in a bullet hit towards right park
is back still back it's over his head
and off the wall
park feels it on a bounce wong digging
for two here's the throw not in
time you have that confidence that
someone's not gonna beat you in you can
still stay on that ball away and shoot
it to the opposite field there's escobar
now
he's third in the national league and
rbis as well
and he just punches one into right field
what a piece of hitting
a run will score and the brewers are on
the board first
a run producing machine the last couple
of years eduardo escobar
doing things just like that everybody
wants to talk about the home runs but
that's just as important right there
a two strike approach on a full count
not a bad pitch it was a change up off
the outside corner and check this out
are you talking about just leaning on
once kind of punching it out into right
field shortening up that stroke making
sure he makes contact
nagowski is the hitter for pittsburgh
but first there's a half swing he goes
and nakowski upset unable to check it
jacob stalling
runway's on it first after the lead off
walk
hit toward the gap and bounces off the
foot of the wall
reynolds on his way home he is going to
score on that double by stallings and he
ties the game stallings goes down and
gets a breaking ball out over the plate
and gets great wood to it just missing a
two run homer off the bottom
of that left center field wall reynolds
with two outs
doesn't have to worry about any
possibility of it being caught he can go
hard all the way
so he scores without a play rodolfo
castro is going to be the battery
there's a cold strike three back door
breaking ball
another strike and his beauty to end the
inning
struck him out looking cody ponce comes
in
sixth appearance 0-2 8-64 the e-r-a
on the backhand to newman sure-handed as
they come
brings up the pitcher peralta and hans
makes quick work of him two up and two
down for cody potts
ryan reynolds will lead off against
freddie peralta and he's got another hit
that's gonna trickle into the corner
that could be three
reynolds heading for third he's in there
standing with a triple
reynolds does a good job of going out
and getting around that
that's just a little get me over
breaking ball from peralta he was just
throwing on the outer half whether brian
reynolds was looking for it or not who
knows
now nagowski infield's still up
and he got a good pitch to hit out there
and he did deep to center
here comes reynolds
he'll score sac fly for nagowski the
pirates have the lead in milwaukee
two on first and second two outs for
kevin newman
one two delivery swing of the mess
struck him out and
the inning is over thomas shortstop has
walked in
light out to the wall and right three
boy that's a good one too you like it in
the zone
where you don't rely on a chase put it
in the zone
figuring adamus is looking heater still
way out in front
that has to get through escobar but gets
the strikeout anyhow
comes right back another 3-2 breaking
ball another one that was
in the zone not that it needed to be is
escobar often
suiter on the pitch freddie peralta
exits now a base hit could score two
three two two outs camel takes a cold
strike three
fastball on the inside corner inning
over chance of rowdy come
raining down two on two outs two-two
pitch
and teles in the air right field he is
watching
park is back goodbye
rony telez three-run
blast brewers take the lead
got the fastball and wrote it on out of
here
three run home run full count
escobar will take off there he goes and
kane down the line base in
over to cut it off is gamel escobar to
third
lorenzo kane with a two-out single
fastball up in the zone he's able to get
on top of it and
rips it into the left there it is up and
in is that back leg hack
by lorenzo kane devin williams on to try
to close it down
it's gonna be gregory polanco to pinch
it paul count two outs
tying run at the plate in the ninth
williams deals
and a swing and a miss he struck him
basketball gave him the gas at 98 miles
an hour
devon williams with his first career big
league save
and the brewers win a thriller this
afternoon